exi poulain bonsoir bonsoir vous avez
bien sûr suire fille est avec nous cette
conférence de presse entre olivier
ferrand et jean castex l'une des mesures
un principal je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est la transformation du pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale votre votre
regard là-dessus
là dessus que j'étais attendu puisque le
gouvernement avance tel un bulldozer par
décret pendant une période de vacances
pour aller plus vite prendre les
français par surprise j'avais avant
cette conférence promis des mesures
illisible je crois qu'on a été servi
après les plages statique où il fallait
bouger sur la plage l'auto attestation
de sortie là on nous a sorti du chapeau
l'interdiction de consommer de boue dans
les bars alors je lève mon verre à cette
formidable mesure un toast à la santé de
jean castex et olivier ferrand parce que
c'est formidable d'un côté on ne peut
plus boire debout dans les bars mais on
ne peut plus boire à sinon plus dans les
cinémas ni manger de pop corn ce sont
deux grandes mesures prises dans cette
guerre contre le coronavirus on peut
voir que là on a mis vraiment tout ce
qu'il fallait après l'ouverture des
fenêtres on fait vraiment des efforts
évidemment voit bien que le xz kuti fait
face à un mur il continue dans cette
stratégie du tout vaccinal avec un aveu
jean castex qui dit que oui ce sont les
non vaccinés et les personnes avec un
schéma vaccinal nom complet qui sont
dans les services de réanimation mais
qu'est ce que ça signifie aujourd'hui un
schéma de vaccination nom complet est ce
que c'est de dos tout simplement alors
là la promesse de la troisième dose
olivier ferrand nous la donne c'est un
reboot de 90% d'immunité pendant
quelques temps et puis à la question est
la quatrième dose olivier vers ans avoue
ne pas savoir et travailler avec les
autorités israéliennes et les instances
internationales
donc sans doute la quatrième dose est à
attendre si on ne sort pas de cette
vague au micron et puis on sort sur les
peurs vagues dans la vague méga vague
super vague vague de delta avec 2
microns on est noyé finalement avec
encore une fois déjà jonction
contradictoires des mesures ubuesque et
puis toujours une seule stratégie
limiter les libertés et faire de la vie
des non vaccinés une impossibilité c'est
à dire honte le pacte républicain de
liberté égalité fraternité et le faire
là c'est là où c'est assez pernicieux en
disant que ces lois scélérates sont des
lois de la république
eh bien non elles sont des lois
totalement scellera puisqu'elles sont
d'eloise prise dans un contexte de
d'urgence sanitaire de 2,2 alors on va
pas employer le terme de dictature
sanitaire mais on va on va dire que là
il ya une gestion totalement hors champ
or non démocratique puisque les
délibérations ont quasiment pas lieu ou
sont fait ultra rapidement sans le temps
du débat éthique ontologique et
démocratique pour simplement forcé les
français à se vacciner et dire que
cocorico la france est le pays le plus
vaccinée du monde mais pour quoi faire
si c'est pour ceux contaminés et
continue et d'attraper le coc vide et
puis comment faire confiance enfin à
jean castex lui qui nous disait que le
vaccin empêcher la contamination est
empêchée de disséminer le virus il ya de
ça quelques mois pourquoi aujourd'hui
alors qu'il nous dit que la troisième
dose protège de micron il faudrait le
croire comment peut-on encore croire ces
gens qui ont raconté tout et son
contraire pendant des mois parce qu'ils
ne savent pas plus que nous comment
faire face à cette crise du coc vite
donc voilà une conférence de presse à ne
nous manquait pas et dire qu un conseil
de défense va encore avoir lieu la
semaine prochaine on repart dans le ja
kadima cronista aller et jacadi il faut
marcher à cloche-pied dans la rue avec
un masque et bien les préfets ferons en
sorte que tous les français le fasse
sans quoi attention à l'amande alors
jean castex là à plein lors de cette
conférence de presse la vaccination
n'empêche pas bien sûr de de contracter
le virus mais empêche en tout cas selon
lui de développer des formes graves vous
avez entendu notre débat tout à l'heure
entre alex fille alexis poulain non
c'est vous entre gilbert collard et
france 4 e bof gilbert collard disait
que la le gouvernement pendant ces deux
ans avait parfois manqué de de pédagogie
et de prudence notamment au moment de ce
genre de dan on sait ce que c'est ça
c'est un sentiment vous vous partagez
mais tout est une mise en scène de père
est en fait depuis le début de cette
crise de la déclaration des manuels
maquereau en face à un hôpital de
campagne sur un supermarché en disant
nous sommes guerre jusqu'à ses
conférences de presse cryptée où il
raconte n'importe quoi avec des éléments
de langage qui sortent de la haute
autorité de santé et puis qui change
tous les mois à peu près après avec en
plus maintenant l'ignominie d'une
politique du bouc-émissaire faire peser
toutes les mesures sur les non vaccinés
mais enfin quand il fait à part ne pas
se vacciner et maintenant honte à eux ce
qui engorge le soi-disant les services
de réanimation mais les non vaccinés
sont les doubles vacciner d'hier que
va-t-il se passer si jamais la troisième
dose n'est pas suffisante le pass et et
vous savez combien j'étais contre cette
mesure dangereuse pour la démocratie et
qui qui rompait le pacte républicain il
ya maintenant le pass est devenu un
outil du quotidien il ne devait pas être
là pour empêcher d'accéder à des
activités du quotidien maintenant si
vous n'êtes pas vacciné fini le cinéma
fini le restaurant fini le reste on est
en train de rentrer dans un monde du
contrôle total c'est ce qu'on appelle la
société de vigilance emmanuel macron
cette société elle n'est pas souhaitable
il faut le dire est et pourquoi parce
que ce n'est pas aux français de
surveiller les autres français de les
empêcher d'avoir des droits qu'ils ont
de fait la liberté elle est inaliénable
tout comme le droit de disposer de son
corps aujourd'hui ce gouvernement par la
contrainte par l'extorsion vaccinale
pousse les français à se vacciner à
multi doses pour soi disant lutter
contre des variants qui on ne connaît
pas encore vont sans doute arriver
puisque ce qu vide maintenant on excelle
quasiment sortis de la phase pandémique
c'est devenu une épidémie saisonnière et
ça ne va pas se finir et d'ailleurs
l'idée verront le disait qu' aujourd'hui
chez les plus jeunes sont à l'hôpital
c'est les enfants avec la bronchiolite
ce ne sont pas les enfants avec le co
vides il y en a quelques-uns et c'est à
déplorer mais pourquoi l'hôpital craques
parce que les gens comme jean castex
comme olivier ferrand ont cassé
l'hôpital public depuis des années
allant même jusqu'à fermer des lits
pendant même la crise pandémique il y a
de cela deux ans donc on est vraiment là
avec des gens qui n'ont pas conscience
de ce qu'ils font qui ont menti ou qui
n'avaient pas les connaissances
nécessaires pour asséner des vérités qui
n'en étaient pas et qui continue de
faire ce cirque qui est une mise en
scène assez triste avec la promesse qui
n'est même plus celle d'une vie d'après
vous vie d'avant mais qui est simplement
de dire nous luttons en réaction aux
nouvelles vagues alors voilà c'est vrai
c'est un film qui a trop duré comme un
mauvais films de la nouvelle vague et
les acteurs que sont jean castex et
olivier ranson fatigué et de sortir
toujours les mêmes éléments de langage
je crois que les français aussi ont
totalement décrochés et quand je parlais
de mesures illisible là on atteint
encore une fois un paroxysme et pourtant
je pensais que c'était impossible merci
beaucoup alexis blanc d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci d'avoir débriefer
avec nous les annonces forts de jean
castex et d'olivier vers ans